Um ôega3 bem dosado, não oxidado, na
forma correta, vale mais que doses
cavalares de produto ruim. E quinto,
individualização é a chave. Não existe
dose única que serve para todo mundo.
Seu contexto de saúde, seus exames, seus
fatores de risco, tudo importa na
decisão. Então a mensagem que quero
deixar é: não saiam tomando ômega-3 de
maneira desordenada,
mas também não ten medo dele baseado em
alguma manchete sensacionalista.
A verdade está no meio como sempre e
precisa ser construída com conhecimento,
exames e acompanhamento adequado. E por
favor, pessoal, aquela conversa, cada um
fala uma coisa, cada um fala uma coisa.
M.